monsieur le ministre vraiment merci à
vous d'être là je suis heureuse que
cette audition sans partage et aussi
avec les membres de la commission des
finances que nous avons invité à
partager cet échange avec vous et je
remercie les collègues qui sont qui sont
en visio alors votre dernière audition
mais c'est le ministre devant notre
délégation remontent au 30 octobre 2010
neuf sous la présidence de notre éminent
collègue jean marie bockel et nous vous
avions auditionné sur deux sujets on va
dire brûlant de l'époque pour les
collectivités territoriales 1 qui
soulevait vous vous en doutez un
enthousiasme extrêmement modéré de la
part des sénateurs s'étaient suppression
de la taxe d'habitation est le deuxième
volet sur lequel nous avions sans doute
un regard plus positif parce que il le
valait bien c'était le texte sur la
transformation de la fonction publique
depuis
nous savons que la crise qu vide est
venue bouleverser toutes les certitudes
sur l'efficacité de l'action publique
mais aussi sur les modalités de
d'exercice de l'action publique et sur
les perspectives financières des
collectivités
celles ci ont répondu depuis mars 2020 à
des demandes et des besoins de la
population qu'il entrait nullement dans
leur champ de compétence mais quand il y
a urgence l oms elle en fait et à tel
point qu'au sortir du premier
confinement en mai 2000 va on a pu
parler d'un séisme financier pour les
finances locales qui était difficilement
chiffrables on parlait de 20 milliards
d'euros pour 2020 et 2021 selon les
associations d'élus et 14 milliards pour
le gouvernement
devant cette incertitude est en même
temps l'urgence de mesurer l'étendue des
de ceux enfin j'ose dire de ces dégâts
et la nécessité d'agir et préparer le
budget
le premier ministre avait recommandé un
rapport sur le sujet à notre collègue
président de la délégation aux
collectivités de l'assemblée jean rené
cazeneuve que nous allons d'ailleurs
recevoir tout à l'heure pour nous
éclairer sur l'actualisation de l'impact
de la crise sanitaire donc au sortir de
l'adoption de la loi de finances pour
2021 qui a arrêté un certain nombre de
mesures relatives aux collectivités
territoriales mais vous avez bien noté
monsieur ministre parce que ça a été
très présent les attentes légitimes de 2
des sénateurs mais aujourd'hui votre
parole est encore très attendu et pour
ma part j'aurais de type de questions
mais j'aimerais qu'on puisse à la fois
sur des questions extrêmement financière
et à court terme mais aussi sur des
réflexions plus plus structurelle je
vais démarrer par celle ci d'ailleurs le
président de la république l'an dernier
a demandé au sénat comme à l'assemblée
nationale des propositions structurelles
fortes pour l'avenir le président du
sénat a constitué un groupe de travail
disons oecuméniques ce qui n'empêche
chaque chaque groupe chaque famille
politique peut avoir
on va dire quelques différences de
points de vue au final mais en tout cas
le sénat a formulé 50 propositions pour
les libertés locales mais en fait le
sujet c'est l'efficacité de l'action
publique comment rendre à nos
concitoyens partout sur le territoire
la meilleure action publique au bon
niveau en optimisant les ressources
quelle qu'elle soit aujourd'hui il nous
semble que l'appétence pour les
propositions du sénat choix à ces
mesures et on l'a vu lors du débat des
ppl et je dirais que le
le projet 3d ou cadets est un peu on dit
dans ma bretagne comme anne dans son
donjon qui dit ma soeur anne ne vois-tu
rien venir alors bon voilà on a un
horizon lointain et incertain ce qui est
un vrai sujet parce que pendant cette
crise
je crois que toutes les missions tous
les acteurs tous les commentateurs ont
bien vu
l'impérieuse nécessité pour une
efficacité de l'action publique très
attendue par nos concitoyens d'une
meilleure organisation des jeux donc il
y avait deux questions ou deux
propositions qui vous concerne plus
particulièrement la première c'est la
proposition du sénat d'instaurer un
rendez vous régulier entre le
gouvernement et le parlement pour
évaluer des compensations financières de
transfert de compétences aux
collectivités locales parce qu'il y a le
transfert des ressources nécessaires au
financement des compétents au moment de
leur transfert mais on sait et on a des
exemples notamment dans les départements
que le coût de ces compétences augmente
non pas de la seule volonté des élus
locaux mais de contraintes ce parfois
réglementaires qui leur sont imposées
donc charles guené oti de la commission
des finances reviendra certainement là
dessus et puis la deuxième proposition
qui faisait suite à ce grand débat qu'on
a eue sur un projet de enfin une loi de
finances pour les collectivités comme on
l'a sur la sécurité sociale on a
beaucoup débattu de ce sujet et cette
proposition n'a pas du tout été retenu
parce qu'elle ne nous semblait pas
optimale et qu'elle pourrait même
constituer un piège pour les
collectivités donc nous avons retenu une
idée
d'un débat annuel au parlement consacrée
aux finances locales
juste avant l'examen par le parlement du
projet de loi de finances initiale parce
qu'on sait que tout ce qui a trait au
financement de compétences des
collectivités et parfois fondu ou
dispersés dans le budget dont j'aimerais
vraiment qu'on puisse parler de de ces
sujets très importants pour pour
l'avenir et des questions plus
conjoncturelle donc la première c'est la
territorialisation du plan de relance
c'est un enjeu budgétaire mais aussi
politique alors je vais pas parler des
modalités de mise en oeuvre du plan de
relance mais dans les 100 milliards
d'euros du plan de relance qu'il est
véritablement la part des mesures
nouvelles
dédié spécifiquement aux collectivités
parce qu'on sait que c'est 100 milliards
embrasse des mesures qui existent déjà
deuxième question on a évoqué les
mesures des dernières lois pour une
notion de filets de sécurité qui
garantirait un niveau minimal de
recettes aux communes et aux
intercommunalités concession de la
baisse des droits de mutation mais on a
aussi voulu c'est bien monsieur le
ministre on en a parlé
la baisse de de recettes des
collectivités liées aux services
enfin dernier point vous avez proposé
avec madame goro une initiative que nous
avons trouvée fort intéressant qui est
celle d'un groupe de travail sur
financement du bloc communal je vais pas
m'attarder mais on ne cesse de dire
depuis des années que quand même
aujourd'hui le financement des
collectivités relève de l'incongruité
d'un empilement de choses qui viennent
se contrarier ou ce qu'on pensait bref
ya peu de visibilité et parfois la
péréquation que l'on fait n'est pas
aussi équitable quel qu'elles devraient
donc ce groupe de travail réunit des
associations d'élus les commissions des
finances des parlements et des dégâts
sion collectivités bernard delcros et
charles guené ont assisté à ce
on va dire à cette entrée en matière que
pouvez vous nous annoncez quant à la
suite de ces travaux
merci monsieur le ministre de répondre à
ces questions les collègues en aurons un
grand nom mais je rappelle que notre
réunion fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo sur le site internet du sénat
merci monsieur le ministre merci madame
la présidente mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs présents dans la salle ou en
visio d'abord permettez moi de vous
souhaiter à toutes et tous et une belle
année 2021 en faisant le souhait
collectif et partagé je crois qu'elles
soient à la fois plus facile et plus
apaisé que celle qui vient de se clore
vous avez dit tout à l'heure madame la
présidente que mon président présent
vous avez indiqué hier qu'il était bien
de commencer à l'heure j'ai l'habitude
de dire mes collaborateurs 4 à l'heure
c'est déjà être en retard donc autant
vous dire que je souscris pleinement à
cette initiative
quelques mots à la fois pour répondre à
vos questions et revenir sur la
situation financière des collectivités
et l'impact que les crises qu vide et
ses conséquences économiques et sociales
peuvent avoir sur ses finances locales
d'abord rappelé que la crise est
intervenue à un moment où les finances
des collectivités
nonobstant des problèmes structurels que
nous connaissons je pense notamment au
financement des dépenses des
départements en matière sociale était
dans une situation d'amélioration
d'amélioration par un excédent qui
allait croissant par un investissement
qui était repartie très fortement sur
2019 et 2018 et cela s'explique à la
fois par la maîtrise des dépenses de
fonctionnement par les collectivités
toutes les collectivités et pas
seulement celles qui avaient été amenés
à être consterné parce qu'on a ce que
nous avons appelé les contrats de cahors
et par le maintien des dotations de
fonctionnement à un niveau global sans
refaire le débat de la répartition
locales et les critères d'accès à la
péréquation est donc cette crise est
aussi intervenu à un moment où le niveau
de trésorerie des collectivités était
important ce qui est assez fréquent mais
ce qui a permis aux collectivités je
crois de faire face ils répondent
présentes comme vous l'avez
rappelé de répondre présent comme vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure nous avons
apporté un certain nombre de réponses
avec vous puisque les pelles fr
successifs ont été voté de manière
extrêmement partys par trans partisane
et partagé tant à l'assemblée qu'au
sénat et les réponses que l'on peut
exister de manière chronologique
d'abord le plfr 3 avec trois éléments de
réponse en pdf r3 d'abord la mise en
place d'un mécanisme d'avancés
remboursables pour les pertes de dmt et
au département
à un moment où vous l'avez rappelé nous
craignons les uns et les autres que la
paire de dmt au puisse atteindre 20 ou
25% sur un modèle ou une comparaison
avec ce qui avait été connue et un peu
plus de dix ans l'occasion de la crise
financière
le deuxième outil qu'était mise en place
et la mise en oeuvre l'inscription dans
la loi d'un mécanisme de garantie des
recettes fiscales et domaniales nous
n'avons pas intégré malgré les demandes
de plusieurs sénateurs et de députés
la compensation des recettes tarifaires
contre considérant la fois que c'était
le secteur sur lequel des économies de
constatation pouvaient être réalisés
parfois difficilement mesuré mais
considérons aussi que l'impact
budgétaire pour l'état aurait été par
trop important et qu'il y avait une
volonté inédite ce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire votre à ce grand
vote rassembler plusieurs fois de
garantir les recettes fiscales et des et
domanial mais que nous ne souhaitions
pas aller au delà en termes de prise en
charge
et puis enfin nous avons inscrit dans le
plf r3 une dotation soutien à
l'investissement local supplémentaire à
hauteur d'un milliard d'euros 40% de
cette des cils d'un milliard d'euros a
été ont été déléguées au cours du mois
d'août 20 % l'ont été depuis et à date
61 % de cette décida été déléguée 60%
fait l'objet d'engagements et les
travaux vont continuer puisque nous
avons acté comme nous nous étions
engagés avec jacqueline gourault le
report d horizon des autorisations
d'engagement et des crédits paiement non
consommés sur l'exercice 2021 pour que
le milliard soit bien pleinement
rendez-vous en termes de soutien à
l'investissement
lors de l'examen presque conjointe du
plfr 4 et du plf
nous avons apporté progressivement et
dans le débat d'autres dispositions et
d'autres ajustements
d'abord pour ce qui concerne le
mécanisme de garantie des recettes
fiscales et domaniales nous avons
procédé à deux modifications
la première consiste à préciser le
montant
à inscrire un élève 2021 puisque tous
les toutes les sommes versées pour le
mécanisme de garantie ne relever que
d'acomptes et nous attendons la fin et
la clôture des exercices 2020 pour
arrêter exactement le menton de cette
garantie dont estimons à 510 millions
d'euros ce qui est bien inférieur à
l'estimation que nous avions faite lors
du mois de juillet et cela tient compte
de la réalité des recettes fiscales
notamment qui ont été perçus par les
collectivités recettes fiscales qui ont
largement mieux résisté que prévu pour
ce qui concerne les dm théo nous sommes
sur des baisses inférieures à 10% par
exemple même si nous savons les uns les
autres qu'il y a de l'hétérogénéité
entre les collectivités locales
je dis d'ailleurs que pour ce qui
concerne l'état les recettes fiscales
ont tout aussi bien résisté que les
recettes des collectivités et que nous
avons l'occasion avec les dernières
semaines du mois de l'année 2020 deux
constantes et que même par rapport à nos
prévisions réactualisées embellie faire
4 et amp élèves 21
nous réalisons je n'ose pas dire des
plus values puisque ça reste très
inférieur à 2019 mais des moins-values
moins importante que ce que que ce que
nous craignons nous avons aussi procédé
à un deuxième ajustement qui consiste à
prolonger pour 2021
le mécanisme de garantie sur la seule
partie des recettes fiscales
je précise évidemment avec un objectif
qui est notamment de tenir compte de
l'effet retard avec lequel la cvae peut
être impacté par les effets de la crise
nous faisons avec un sentiment assez
rassuré si je dois vous dire la vérité
dans la mesure où les prévisions dont
nous disposons qui ne sont pas tout à
fait arrêtée car vous savez que le
système des acomptes d'avoir un effet
positif une année avoir un effet négatif
a contrario l'année suivante mais
nos prévisions à date nous laisse
envisager une diminution de la cvae en
2020 de manière globale entre 2 et 2 5%
ce qui est là aussi très inférieur à ce
que nous craignons les uns et les autres
et ce qui est assez cohérent avec
maintien de la tva à un niveau moins
dégradés que prévu et nous faisons
évidemment un lien entre ces deux
fiscalités nous avons aussi prévu avec
le plfr 4 et le pelley 21 d'améliorer ce
mécanisme de garantie en intégrant une
disposition spécifique aux communes de
moins de 5000 habitants pour leur
garantir sous forme de compensation le
niveau ddmt haut puisque les communes de
moins de 5000 habitants perçoivent les
dm théo avec un décalage d'un an par
rapport aux départements ou communes
plus importantes
enfin nous avons intégré trois
dispositions particulières une première
disposition pour abonder le fonds de
péréquation ddmt ou entre département à
hauteur de 60 millions d'euros de
manière à garantir que ce fonds de
péréquation garde la dynamique en termes
de volume qui avait été arrêté c'est un
geste unilatéral de la part de l'état
pour accompagner le maintien de la
péréquation entre départements qui nous
semblait utile puisque nous savons que
cette péréquation profil aux
départements les plus fragiles
nous avons intégré une disposition qui
est sans commune mesure en termes de
financement nous sommes sur une dizaine
de millions d'euros pour faciliter et
permettre la prise en charge de 50 % du
loyer du mois de novembre lorsqu'une
collectivité abandonne le loyer du mois
de novembre au profit d'un locataire
commerçant ou d'un locataire entreprises
sur le modèle de ce que nous avons fait
avec un crédit d'impôt pour le secteur
privé et enfin et surtout si je puis
dire
nous avons intégré un dispositif
d'avancés remboursables sur le même
modèle que les dmto c'est-à-dire
assortie d'une forme de d'euros de
clause de retour à bonne fortune pour
les autorités organisatrices de mobilité
en tenant compte sur le modèle de ce que
nous avions discuté avec ile-de-france
mobilité à la fois de la perte
diversement mobilité mais aussi la perte
de recettes tarifaires et c'est la seule
dérogation au mentor ce que nous faisons
pr règle notre propre ligne de conduite
de non prise en compte des recettes
tarifaires mais du fait de la
spécificité des services de transport en
commun sur 7 sur ce point là je disais
c'est peut-être la disposition
principale pour le plf 21 et le plfr 4
dans la mesure où cela concerne un peu
plus d'un milliard 900 millions d'euros
1,1 milliard 2 pour ile-de-france
mobilité et 950 millions d'euros pour
les autorités organisatrices des
mobilités des autres régions j'ajoute
mais vous l'avez en tête que le pellec
21 se traduit aussi par le maintien du
niveau global des dotations de
fonctionnement le maintien des
trajectoires péréquation verticale pour
la ds wii la dsr et le maintien des
dotations à l'investissement classique
des le terre des cils indépendamment de
ce que nous avions proposé que vous
aviez adopté en paix les faire 3 ainsi
que d'autres concours aux
investissements puisque nous sommes
autour d'une grosse dizaine de milliards
d'euros au total
deux concours de l'état aux
investissements des collectivités même
si dans nos débats nous nous arrêtons
souvent à la bio terre et à la dsi le
pen 21 et c'est le troisième point que
je veux aborder prévoit aussi un certain
nombre de dispositions qui tiennent au
plan de relance de manière extrêmement
spécifique et je reviendrai en
conclusion sur la question la
territorialisation du plan de relance
que vous avez abordé madame la
présidente
nous avons d'abord acté un certain
nombre de dispositions dans le désordre
et sans ordre de priorité je pense
notamment à l'aide aux maires bâtisseurs
qui sera versée en deux échéances août
2021 et où 2022
sans que les communes aient à faire
quelques démarches que ce soit puisque
sont les services de l'état qui pour
mesurer la délivrance d'autorisation de
construction de rénovation sur les
territoires considérés comme dance nous
sommes sur environ 350 millions d'euros
et puis nous avons acté je tiens à
m'arrêter un instant sur ce point là une
fête de flécher une partie des crédits
que l'état consacre à la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments vers les
collectivités territoriales nous avons
inscrit dans le plan de relance
au total quatre milliards d'euros pour
le soutien à la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments publics
les 4 milliards d'euros il ya deux sets
qui ont été fléchés sur les bâtiments de
l'état ou des universités ces deux
milliards sept ont été attribués la
semaine du 15 décembre à 4214 projet
avec une volonté de nous appuyer volonté
aujourd'hui un constat sur le travail
fait par les préfets et les préfets de
région et nous avons privilégié à chaque
fois que nous l'avons pu des opérations
de moins de cent mille euros ce qui
correspond au seuil de déclenchement des
marchés publics en application de la loi
zappé pour les projets qui relèvent de
la relance nous avons aussi acté qu'au
delà de ces deux milliards 7 300
millions d'euros seraient consacrés à la
rénovation thermique des lycées dans le
cadre de chantiers menés par les régions
avec une compétence donnée au préfet de
région pour accompagner contractualiser
avec les régions sur le financement de
la rénovation thermique des lycées il y
à 50 millions d'euros qui sont consacrés
des opérateurs il reste 9 150 millions
d'euros qui seront consacrés à la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments des
collectivités locales nous avons décidé
avec j'ai fait une grosse que ses 950
millions d'euros qui initialement devait
faire l'objet d'un appel à projet ne
serait pas gérer un appel à projets en
connaissant les limites
nous allons demander au préfet de région
d'accompagner les collectivités pour
leurs entreprises leurs chantiers de
rénovation thermique avec des modalités
d'attribution de cet argent qu'ils
soient des modalités proches voire
comparable identiques à celles de la ds
il ce qui est évidemment moins
chronophage que la procédure d appel à
projets notre objectif est que les
collectivités puissent être accompagnés
et notre objectif est que le plan de
relance puissent concerner tous les
territoires
il y a des gens bien la question la
territorialisation des mesures qui sont
très spécifiques aux collectivités celle
que je viens d'évoquer j'aurais pu
ajouter les 300 millions d'euros qui
sont l'objet pour le coup d'appel à
projets en matière d'accompagnement des
projets de mobilité par les intercoms
par les régions on vise principalement
les intercours en la matière et s'agit
là de sommes qui sont véritablement
consacrée au suivi des collectivités
locales
de la même manière vous avez
certainement pris connaissance du décret
du 28 décembre qui ouvre comme je m'y
étais engagé comme amélie deux manches
elle
s'y est engagée à ma suite l'aide à
l'aide l'embauché d'apprentis aux
collectivités locales puisque nous
avions indiqué notre volonté que les
collectivités locales soient accompagnés
comme les employeurs privés en matière
de recours à l'apprentissage
au delà il ya dans le plan de relance
des mesures qui évidemment font l'objet
de d'utilisation de me dit de
déploiement conforme à des règles
nationales ou confiés à des opérateurs
au niveau local je pense notamment aux
agences sur lesquels il est compliqué de
dire que telle somme ou tel autre somme
sera définitivement mais précisément
consacré aux collectivités dans la
mesure où ça relève souvent de logique
d'appel à projets d'accompagnement ça
dépend donc d'initiative et de leur
capacité à être sélectionné où il est
monté et puis j'ajoute une précision qui
a son importance
nous souhaitons que le déblocage le
développe le déploiement du plan de
relance soit rapide et nous avons prévu
des clauses de revoyure extrêmement
sévère pour faire en sorte que lorsque
les budgets ne sont pas consommés puisse
être redéployés sur d'autres actions je
pense par exemple à des actions qui
marche très fort comme la numérisation
des entreprises ou terry tome industries
du futur et donc il nous obligeront à un
moment ou un autre
à deir des pommes je précise enfin que
nous avons prévu des accords avec les
régions et que nous avons aussi prévu et
autoriser une circulaire a été publiée
au cours du mois de décembre des accords
un frère infra régionaux de relance pour
permettre à des départements et des
intercommunalités de contractualiser
directement avec l'état pour
l'accompagnement des projets qui sont
des leurres dès lors qu'ils s'inscrivent
en écho avec les priorités du plan de
relance
où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui j'en
termine par un par là les informations
dont je dispose à cette heure sont les
suivantes concernant l'état des comptes
des collectivités locales je précise qu
elles ne sont pas définitives puisque
nous sommes encore dans la journée
supplémentaire et que toutes les
opérations n'ont pas été enregistrés au
30 décembre 2020 les dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités locales
sont de manière très global en hausse
pour 2020 de 0 4% par rapport à 2010 9
ce qui est beaucoup moins que ce que
nous imaginions du fait des impacts de
la crise les recettes de fonctionnement
sont heureuses de 1 3% ce qui nous évite
de manière très globale très macro de
rencontrer l'effet ciseau que nous
craignons mais il faut noter que en 2019
l'augmentation des recettes était à 2 8%
et qu'il ya donc une baisse
significative
nous constatons une épargne brute qui
progresse toujours à date au 30 décembre
de 8 3%
mais j'ajoute immédiatement que ces
chiffres sont évidemment très macro
qu'ils ont des déclinaisons par strates
de collectivités qui sont différentes et
que au sein d'une même strate de
collectivité nous rencontrons des
situations hétérogènes en fonction de la
structure économique des territoires et
de la structure de leurs recettes et que
comme à l'accoutumée ces chiffres
'macro' rencontre toujours des
traductions différentes sur les
territoires il y a j'y reviendrai
certainement à l'occasion des questions
un point que je n'ai pas abordé qui est
la compensation des impôts de production
nous en avons deux longuement débattu en
séance ici mêmes et à l'assemblée mais
si vous avez des questions
complémentaires j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure il y a enfin quelques enjeux que
vous avez évoqué madame la présidente et
qui rejoignent notre volonté l'enjeu des
dépenses sociales
nous le savons et ça fait l'objet de
discussions qui sont aussi compliquées
qu'elles l'ont été les années
précédentes mais c'est normal vu
l'ampleur et l'importance des enjeux et
elle continue il ya un enjeu sur
l'investissement et le rythme de
l'investissement puisque si la situation
des collectivités se dégradent beaucoup
moins que ce que nous craignons il y a
quand même cet enjeu d'investissement et
ce besoin de visibilité c'est
malheureusement aussi lié à la situation
épidémique
et puis les un certain nombre d'enjeux
structurel est d'ores et déjà je puis
vous affirmer que le groupe de travail
que nous avons mis en place avec
jacqueline gourault qui ressemble ou qui
pourrait jouer ce rôle d'observatoire
des analyses à la fois des évolutions
mais aussi de l'hétérogénéité de la
situation d'un groupe de travail auquel
nous tenons et que nous allons continuer
à réunir pour affiner cette connaissance
et se partage des connaissances sur la
situation des collectivités que l'idée
d'un rendez vous réguliers comme vous le
propose y ait d'un débat sur la
situation des finances locales et une
proposition qui à titre personnel me
paraît tout à fait intéressante et si
j'ose dire
le membre du gouvernement que je suis
répondre et évidemment à toute
convocation initiative du sénat ou de
l'assemblée
si un tel débat a été organisé sous nous
étions conviés
je partage la même réserve que celle que
vous avez évoquées concernant la loi de
financement des collectivités
territoriales c'est un point auquel j'ai
réfléchi à plusieurs reprises et qui
pouvait paraître séduisant mais qui
après réflexion paraît assez compliquée
dans la mesure où l'analogique est
souvent faite avec la loi financement de
la sécurité sociale ne tient pas puisque
les recettes des systèmes de santé sont
relativement maîtrisée par l'état à
l'exception du niveau de l'assiette mais
ça les cotisations s'applique à une
assiette qui évolue comme la fiscalité
sa fille une assiette qui évolue et il
me paraît assez improbable d'imaginer
une loi de financement qui s'appuierait
sur des dépenses qui seraient par nature
à la main des collectivités et sur des
recettes dans la connaissance par le
parlement au moment du vote ne serait
que très parcellaire puisque dépendant
aussi des délibérations de plus de 50000
collectivités ou établissements pouvant
d'une manière ou d'une autre
fixer leur niveau de recettes par des
taux d à peine de contribution donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle je partage
vos réserves et je trouve plus séduisant
si je puis dire
l'idée d'un débat annuel pour avoir une
visibilité un débat d'ensemble sur les
collectivités sans s'arrêter à ce que
nous avons tous connu à un moment ou un
autre c'est à dire un débat sur les
variables d'ajustement et les évolutions
parfois la marge d'un système plutôt que
sur le principal puisque nous savons les
uns et les autres que souvent ce sont
sur des franges du bloc et de l'
enveloppe normée des concours de l'état
aux collectivités que nous discutons
sans revenir sur les masques les plus
importantes
et peut-être que le débat que vous
évoquez nous permettrait d'avoir cette
vision plus globale et plus large je ne
suis pas certain madame à présent
d'avoir répondu à toutes les questions
vous avez posé mais ce n'est pas le cas
j'y reviendrai en répondant aux autres
sénateurs
merci monsieur le ministre alors je ne
pense pas qu'il s'agit d'un oubli
volontaire
il y avait une question également
complémentaires que j'avais posé sur
l'instauration d'un rendez vous
réguliers pour parler de la réévaluation
de compensation financière de transfert
de compétences c'est un vrai sujet vous
le savez bien
je veux je veux pas croire que l'oubli
de cette question était volontaire
knicks et la suffit un correspondent à
un déni des choses dont j'aimerais bien
voilà que vous puissiez donner un un
avis sur ce sujet et avant de passer la
parole au collègue et beaucoup de
collègues veulent prendre la parole je
dirai juste monsieur le ministre
un mot sur les appels à projets je vous
avoue que je sens dans les territoires
une forme d'irrigation d'agacement sur
la multiplication des appels à projets
qui viennent de la part de l'état mais
aussi des collectivités alors en soit
l'idée elle peut être pertinente et
intelligente mais qu' on voit beaucoup
de collectivités qui s'y souffle à
répondre à des appels à projets qui
mobilisent de leads générés
mais aussi beaucoup de finances et qui
au final ne passe pas l'obstacle alors
que parfois ces collectivités ont
mobilisé tous leur conseil municipal ont
mobilisé la population est un site x
dédire bas notre dossier ne devait pas
être suffisamment on n'a pas été les
prix et puis il retenu et puis il ya
toutes les collectivités qui n'ont pas
les moyens de dos voilà c'est pas
l'objet de notes des bas mais je
souhaite passer un message chipie
monsieur mini juste pour clore j'ai bien
entendu que les recettes des
collectivités pouvait dépendre des
délibérations qu'elle prenait sur leurs
taux de fiscalité je vous avoue que là
on va gagner du temps parce qu'on a de
moins en moins
d'autonomie donc la sphère va être un
peu réglé donc je voudrais bien vous
répondiez à ma dernière mission et
ensuite j'ai pour l'instant cinq prises
de paroles 6 voilà n'hésitez pas chers
collègues
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
répondre deux points d'abord sur sur
l'autonomie pour dire que type des
enjeux que j'ai évoqué des débats je
pense que nous aurons à affronter ce
débat sur un choix entre l'autonomie
fiscale l'autonomie financière et les
conséquences que cela peut entraîner sur
le rendez vous que vous évoquez c'est un
sujet qui nous paraît extrêmement
intéressant et qui permettrait
effectivement d'avoir de la clarté et de
la visibilité
j'ai eu l'occasion de demander un groupe
d'experts et d'anciens responsables
politiques de travailler sur les
perspectives en matière de finances
publiques et de gouvernance des finances
publiques
une proposition utile qui pourrait être
vu je n'étais pas dans le déni mais je
me préparais à répondre à cette question
lorsque le sénateur d'allier serait
intervenu sur la compensation des taxes
foncières pour les logements sociaux
puisque nous avons quelques sujets
récurrents et pour lesquels par ailleurs
nous nous partageons le constat d'une
compensation qui n'est pas intégral qui
est aussi le fruit de très longues
années d'érosion de mise en place de
mécanismes mais cela fait partie des
choses qui nous permettront d'y voir
plus clair
il ya une question de méthode sur la
détermination de ce qui relève d'une
décision imposée de ce qui relève d'une
décision partagée ou d'une décision
totalement décentralisé ou déléguer ce
qui rendrait ce rendez-vous pas
nécessairement simple à monter mais en
tout cas intéressant est la dernière
chose sur les appels à projets
si nous avons fait ce choix de confier
le déploiement des 950 millions d'euros
des de la rénovation thermique au préfet
sur les mêmes modalités que la ds il
sait pas ce que nous entendons le même
lassitude que celle que vous évoquez et
que par ailleurs avec jacqueline
gourault nous devons tous les deux
l'occasion de diriger des collectivités
de taille relativement modeste et que
nous savons que trop l'épuisement et la
difficulté à positionner parfois
certaines collectivités se les appels à
projets et enfin toute dernière chose
j'ai un chiffre
que je ne vous les citer et que je n'ai
pas cité tout à l'heure parce qu'on
regarde au titre des mesures d'urgence
et des mesures de garanties que nous
portons pour les départements pour le
bloc local et indépendamment du milliard
de ds il nous arrivons à 4,2 milliards
d'euros mobilisés pour participer au
maintien des recettes des collectivités
en fonctionnement et j'intègre les
impôts m
et je n'intègre pas dans ce chiffre le
milliard de ds il nie les 950 millions
d' aide à la rénovation thermique qui
relève pour nous de la section
d'investissement et pas de
fonctionnement bien évidemment sur
ministre n'hésitez pas à contaminer de
manière positive le gouvernement sur
l'appétence que vous avez pour les
excellentes proposition du sénat donc si
prise de parole didier rambaud puis
charles guené laurent burgoa céline
brulin bernard delcros philippe dallier
voilà didier merci madame la présidente
monsieur ministre 2 deux questions une
comme vous savez je suis parlementaire
de l'isère donc d'un département de
montagne et donc vous faire un zoom plus
particuliers sont les stations de ski et
est rappelé à l'ensemble de mes
collègues effectivement les stations de
ski
c'est une donnée importante de notre
économie beaucoup d'emplois de recettes
fiscales
nous avons aussi un important
constructeur mondial de remontées
mécaniques alors bien sûr s'agit pas ce
n'est pas le lieu de débattre de
l'opportunité ou pas de la réouverture
des remontées mécaniques mais néanmoins
de tout poser une question sur les
mesures soutien qui peuvent être
envisagées par le gouvernement pour les
communes touristiques est rude et
effectivement des tas de mesures de
soutien pour les exploitations les
exploitants remontées mécaniques les
commerces les vis-à-vis des saisonniers
les moniteurs de ski et de toutes les
activités touristiques et hôtelières qui
sont liées au fonctionnement des
stations de sports d'hiver mais mais les
communes aussi font également pertes
face à des pertes de recettes je voulais
vous donner un chiffre qui est assez
révélateur lorsque vous achetez un euro
dans un forfait de ski derrière ce sont
7 euros de dépenses supplémentaires qui
sont qui sont générés deuxième question
qui nous l'avait un peu on l'a peu
abordé sur la question du rendez vous
entre le parlement et le ministère sur
les l'évolution des finances locales
dans le rapport de jean rené cazeneuve
notre collègue député il ya une
proposition de créer un observatoire
suivi de l'impact de la crise sur les
finances locales je trouve c'est
personnellement cette idée forte
intéressante parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
en train de faire face à une bataille de
chiffres
engagés par les élus et donc je le
gouvernement évite doit permettre aux
collectivités de de voir plus clair face
à justement à ce florilège de chiffres
qui sont avancés par les uns et les
autres
donc ce ministre comment comptez vous
prendre en compte la cette
recommandation du collège 15,9 de
création de cette ode de cet
observatoire est le cas échéant
peut-être de préciser le le calendrier
de mise en place merci question de
charles guené laurent burgoa si vous
êtes d'accord monsieur le ministre
ok shanxi merci madame la présidente
merci aussi à monsieur le ministre pour
les précisions qui qu'ils nous ont
apportés les questions que j'ai posées
recoupent aussi celle de mon collègue
mais ça ne vous étonnera pas
simplement en ce qui concerne les
compensations collectivités locales du
fait de la pandémie
je ne suis pas de ceux qui ont
l'habitude de crier au loup sans raison
donc je trouve que si on a une approche
plus enfin - moins grave que celle qu'on
qui était attendu je m'en réjouis
simplement on voit très bien que votre
analyse est quand même et vous le dit
d'ailleurs en regardant l'état des
collectivités locales est assez
macroéconomiques par le fait alors on
sait que ne serait ce que par les
problèmes tarifaires et toutes ces
choses là on peut avoir quand même des
problèmes locaux etc
est-ce que vous excluez ou est ce que
vous envisagez lorsque on l'espère la
panda bear sera terminé un examen et des
mesures qui pourraient être ponctuel sur
des des collectivités qui auraient subi
des dégâts particuliers où nous deuxième
élément on a abordé le la possibilité
d'un budget identifiés pour les
collectivités locales alors et vous
venez de dire votre préférence pour un
débat pour un débat annuel
nous avons eu aussi hier la commission
des finances à la la cour des comptes et
on a pu évoquer un peu aussi d'autres
initiatives en la matière et on voit
très bien que deux en tout état de cause
la la trajectoire des finances publiques
comme la maîtrise générale de la
structure des finances publiques échappe
de plus en plus au parlement et qu'il
faut qu'on fasse quelque chose
et est ce que en plus de ce débat qui
nous paraît intéressant
vous n'envisagez pas rossi c'est quelque
chose que qui m'est cher c'est de
travailler un peu plus cette gouvernance
systémique comme comme on le dit et
effectivement ça recoupe rossi prat est
une possibilité observatoire mais aussi
comme dans des pays qui nous entourent
une relation permanente entre état
collectivités locales et parlement pour
qu'on puisse effectivement avec la part
d'impôts nationaux qui sont aujourd'hui
dans les ressources des collectivités
locales donc mettre en place cette
nouvelle gouvernance qu'on qu'en pensez
vous et troisièmement et dernière
question
on a vu qu'on remarque mais ça rejoint
un peu ma question précédente que très
souvent aujourd'hui dans les textes on a
une absence de volet financier on voit
la loi 3d on nous indique que que
effectivement on va discuter de beaucoup
de choses mais lorsqu'on évoque le feu
lève financier on le dit pour l'instant
il n'est pas question de mettre à velet
financer dans la loi 3d et je vous avoue
qu'en tant que parlementaire ça me
choque qu'on puisse discuter de
transfert de compétences etc et qu' on
n'est pas volée financer et de la même
manière on a eu
lorsqu'on a fait la loi mobilité
lorsqu'il est s'est agi de regarder
comme on allait travailler d'un mobilité
dans les territoires ruraux il y avait
une possibilité d'évoquer un volet
financier il n'a pas eu lieu et on voit
dans quelle situation on est à deux mois
de l'échéance du transfert aux régions
ou non ou les collectivités locales du
territoire ont un choix à faire et
qu'elles n'ont pas les moyens de le
faire parce que ce volet financier n'est
pas complet qu'en pensez vous
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre le nouveau sénateur que je suis
traité leur vous remercier pour votre
disponibilité votre écoute
je trouve que vous faites partie des des
ministres qui sont le plus à l'écouté
parlementaire je tenais à vous le dire
en tant que nouveau sénateur
j'aimerais vous vous interrogez par
rapport au rsa en prenant un cas
pratique que je connais bien c'est à
dire le département du gard où nous
avons plus de trente mille bénéficiaires
du rsa avec une augmentation depuis mars
dernier de 2000 nos bénéficiaires avec
pour le budget 2021 donc plus 10
millions d'euros en dépassé avec une
recette de l'état qui pourrait faire
sourire de plus 5000 euros par rapport à
à cela donc vous commandez très bien que
les élus gardois attendent avec
impatience de voir comment le
l'expérience de notre collègue philippe
dallier de renationalisation du rsa dans
son département qui est cher va se
passer nous regarde nous regarderons
cela avec la plus grande attention
monsieur le ministre et dans mon cas
pratique j'ai une question directe
lorsqu'un département vous demandera au
gouvernement s'il peut reprendre à sa
charge le leur et sackey l'année de
référence sera prise en compte pour
cette renationalisation
après les réponses de monsieur ministre
j'inviterai céline brulin bernard
delcros et philippe dallier
monsieur le ministre merci est nommée
présidente quelques mots pour répondre
aux trois intervenants dans l'ordre de
leur prise de parole d'abord pour
répondre aux sénateurs rambo sur les
questions de stations de ski le
mécanisme de soutien nous avons mise en
place d'un double mécanisme puisqu'il
s'agit à la fois de veiller à ce que les
commerces situés en station de ski soit
rousse éligibles au fonds de solidarité
avec sept évoluent cette évolution des
règles qui fait que c'était 1500 euros
par mois
dix mille pour les pertes d'activité du
mois de novembre
je saisis l'occasion pour indiquer à
votre délégation que nous avons
indemnisés pour la perte d'activité de
novembre plus de huit cent vingt mille
entreprises pour un total de 3 milliards
6 le mode des sombres
c'est un plan à dix mille euros ou
alternativement 20% du chiffre
d'affaires constatée en décembre 2019 la
faune et à 200000 euros et nous avons
annoncé et je le souligne parce que cela
répondra à des difficultés propres
stations de ski la volonté que nous
avons avec bono maire de revoir
dispositif pour janvier notamment pour
tenir compte des entreprises dont les
coûts fixes sont particulièrement
importants et qui par leurs
organisations notamment de séduire tout
ristic se heurte à des questions de
plafond et notamment le plafond des
d'avis en minéraux et donc nous
trouveront là aussi des moyens
d'accompagner les acteurs du tourisme en
particulier du tourisme hivernal
il faut ajouter à cela la prise en
charge à hauteur de ce cent dix mille
euros des pertes d'exploitation des
remontées mécaniques et je précise que
cette prise en charge des pertes
d'exploitation est valable pour des
entreprises de remontées mécaniques
comme pour les services publics de
remontées mécaniques notamment les
régimes nous avons annoncé c'est
elisabeth baume qui l'a fait le maintien
de la prise en charge de l'activité
partielle à 100% et il y à un point que
nous n'avons peut-être pas suffisamment
souligné mais qui concerne directement
les collectivités qui accueille les
stations de ski
c'est le fait que nous ayons avec le
votre accord et votre soutien et même à
votre demande
reporter est prolongée le mécanisme de
garantie des recettes fiscales
cela couvre la question des taxes de
séjour et le fait de l'avoir prolongée
sur l'année 2021 va aussi permettre de
prendre en compte pour les collectivités
la perte de taxe de séjour par rapport à
une inhabituelle par rapport à la
référence 2017 2019 liée à l'absence de
fréquentation ou à la baisse forte de
fréquentation dans les stations de ski
mais la principale réponse tient dans le
fonds de solidarité son extension et
celle à laquelle nous allons procéder
dans les jours qui viennent sur les
questions de l'observatoire et cela
rejoint une question posée par charles
guené tout de suite après le groupe de
travail que nous avons mises en place
avec jacqueline gourault tient pour nous
ce rôle d'observatoire je ne suis pas
sûr alors peut-être que nous devrons le
formaliser le le structurer de manière
plus officielle mais je pense que
l'essentiel est d'avoir la connaissance
et la connaissance partagée plutôt que
de nous intéresser nous concentrer sur
la structure et la nature juridique de
la structure qui nous re qui nous réunit
nous avons ouvert les débats avec
jacqueline il ya maintenant quelques
semaines nos services travaillent avec
les services des associations d'élus et
avec les collaborateurs des
parlementaires directement concernés
pour ce qui concerne le mois de janvier
la réunion technique s'est tenue mardi
donc il ya deux jours et d'ici la fin de
cette semaine au plus tard le tout début
de la semaine prochaine nous serons en
capacité de partager avec votre
délégation est avec celle de l'assemblée
les éléments qui ont été partagés sur
lesquels se sont accordés ils se sont
retrouvés les collaborateurs des
associations comme les collaborateurs du
gouvernement sur la situation des
collectivités locales je pense vraiment
que c'est ce travail qui comptent plutôt
que
la forme en tant que tels que cela peut
prendre et le fait que ce soit partagée
nous paraît très important sur les
questions évoquées par charles guené il
ya un instant je pense évidemment que le
sénateur a raison lorsqu'il dit que
l'analyse est très macro je disais moi
même qu'il ya beaucoup d'hétérogénéité
cette situation c'est une des raisons
qui nous a amenés à prévoir un mécanisme
de garantie qui se calculent
collectivités par connectivité à
l'initiative des directeurs
départementaux des finances publiques
pour les recettes fiscales et domaniale
en vain et uniquement fiscale en 21
parce que ça peut répondre à cette
hétérogénéité parce que l'hétérogénéité
concerne la perte de recettes tout
particulièrement plutôt qu'une réponse
globale
évidemment nous accompagnons des
collectivités en situation particulière
il y à un élément rassurant qui tient au
fait que le nombre de collectivités
inscrits en réseau d' alerte n'a pas
significativement augmenté au cours de
l'année 2020 ce qui est plutôt rassurant
et l'essentiel des collectivités
inscrits dans ce réseau d' alerte
présente les mêmes caractéristiques
c'est à dire plutôt d'être ultra marines
et pas nécessairement un impact et pour
certaines d'entre elles aussi durement
que des collectivités métropolitaines
par le cos ville mais là aussi il ya une
forme d'hétérogénéité nous accompagnons
les collectivités qui rencontrent des
difficultés par des avances de fiscalité
de la vente aux dotations
cela concerne quelques dizaines de
collectivités pour la vis pour la dose
les deux les avances de dotation et
quelques centaines pour les avances de
fiscalité est essentiellement lié à des
problèmes de trésorerie et il y à un
examen qui est au cas par cas et par
ailleurs j'ai eu l'occasion mais dans
des occasions d'aider des quantités vous
pardonnez moi un nombre assez peu
important une dizaine ou une quinzaine
d'accorder un certain nombre de
dérogations aux règles comptables
notamment pour permettre à des
collectivités pas nécessairement
d'ailleurs en lien qu'avec la crise qu
vides ayant des réserves des provisions
en investissement de faire des
transferts de la section de
fonctionnement lorsque ça répondait là
des situations de difficultés
particulières sur la question de la
fragmentation et de la visibilité
je partage je partage la remarque et
cela fait partie des points de l'ordre
du jour en tout cas des sujets
dont nous avons que nous avons demandé à
la commission présidée par jean arthuis
d'aborder notamment pour avoir une
visibilité sur l'ensemble de la dépense
publique l'ensemble des recettes
publiques et faire en sorte que les
liens qui existent entre les trois
grandes sphères de la dépense publique
soit plus connu c'est le cas pour les
collectivités c'est aussi le cas pour la
dépense sociale surtout maintenant que
nous connaissons une situation hors
crise
j'ai bien hors crise ou presque la
moitié des recettes de la sécurité
sociale est liée à de la fiscalité
porté par l'état et non adéquat et des
cotisations sur le calcul des
compensations j'ai eu l'occasion d'y
revenir mais vous avez pardonnez moi je
suis confus évoqué l'absence de volet
financier dans un certain nombre de lois
thématiques
il s'agit là d'un sujet qui me rend
schizophrène c'est à dire que l'ancien
parlementaire je suis trouvé utile
intéressant d'avoir une vision et des
dispositions financières dans les textes
thématiques
le ministre des comptes publics que je
suis est très attaché au monopole de la
loi de finances sera la matière et c'est
là la difficulté alors quand il s'agit
de transferts on peut avoir une réponse
avec le rappel des règles de calcul des
allocations de compensation du des
commissions transferts de charges mais
nous n'avons pas les sommes qui sont
inscrits et ça nécessite une
coordination avec les textes financiers
qui n'est pas toujours évidente mais
comme je disais je suis partagé entre la
responsabilité que j'exerce et l envie
d'en vouloir plus
parce que je suis amené à voter enfin
sur les questions de rsa d'abord pour
dire à monsieur le sénateur que je ne
sais pas répondre immédiatement à sa
question sur l'année de référence
ça fait partie des discussions et il ya
plusieurs hypothèses qui sont encore
ouvertes
les expérimentations aussi cet objectif
là si je pouvais avancer une année où
dire si la moyenne et troisième des
trois dernières années comme pour
l'outre-mer ça serait plus facile pour
moi aujourd'hui mais ça fait encore
partie des discussions avec l'adf donc
il faut trouver un point d'équilibré sur
ce sujet là et dire que nous espérons
évidemment que les expérimentations
nourrissent ce débat on est aujourd'hui
sur
l'augmentation des dépenses en matière
d'allocation individuelles de solidarité
exactement sur le même schéma que ce que
je décris depuis tout à l'heure c'est à
dire une très grande hétérogénéité
on est sur une augmentation moyenne à
date toujours à date inférieure à 2%
or il ya des départements qui ont des
augmentations qui dépasse les 15% et
d'autres qui ont une forme de stabilité
de la dépense en la matière ça tient
beaucoup à la structure économique des
territoires et au fait que les plus
impactés les plus touchés par la crise
sont souvent ceux qui avaient plusieurs
emplois plusieurs temps partiel
travailler dans des domaines soient
touristiques saisonniers événementiel et
l'arrêt des activités les précipite dans
une forme de pression de précarité donc
de minima sociaux
on retrouve selon la typologie du
territoire une augmentation plus ou
moins forte des allocataires du rsa donc
comme l'a aussi la hausse moyenne est
beaucoup moins importante que ce que
nous imaginons mais territoire par
territoire ça peut être beaucoup plus
fort dans certains territoires que dans
d'autres et y compris dans des
territoires connus pour leur dynamisme
économique c'est ce qui est assez
frappant j'ajoute enfin que
habituellement le fonds de stabilisation
qui a voté chaque année en plfr de fin
d'exercice est à hauteur de 115 millions
d'euros pour l'année 2020
nous l'avons porté à 200 millions
d'euros et le premier ministre a eu
l'occasion d'annoncer que pour 2021 il
sera aussi à 200 millions d'euros
avec dans ses modalités d'attribution le
souci d'accompagner les départements les
plus fragilisés par l'augmentation des
dépenses sociales
céline puis bernard puis philippe merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué un certain
nombre de montants financiers
je pense par exemple à la traduction du
mécanisme de garantie que vous avez
évalué à 510 millions d'euros est ce que
vous avez aussi fait évaluer puisque
vous avez débat sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres
sur l'année de référence prise en compte
et qu'un certain nombre d'élus et de
leurs associations suggéré de prendre
plutôt les trois dernières années est ce
que vous avez évaluer la proposition qui
est celle des élus même chose sur les
recettes tarifaires vous avez dit que
prendre en compte les recettes
tarifaires seraient trop lourds pour
l'état ce que je peux tout à fait
entendre mais est-ce que vous avez
évaluer tout ça je dis ça parce que on
nike au et là encore un certain nombre
d'associations d'élus alerte là dessus
sur le fait que des communes notamment
vont avoir des difficultés s'engager
dans la relance
pour des raisons
financière et que peut-être qu est ce
qui peut paraître trop lourd à un moment
est aussi de nature à agir sur la
relance à plus long terme est donc à
considérer en termes d'investissements à
long terme
je dis cela d'autant plus que la
situation est la crise financière est
peut-être plus durable qu'on imaginait
les uns et les autres et que les
collectivités vont de nouveau être
sollicitée voire même elles n'ont pas
besoin d'être sollicitée elle se propose
par exemple pour contribuer à la
vaccination en mettant des sites des
lieux à disposition où on organise en
organisant des transports puisque je
sais qu'un certain nombre d'entre elles
envisagent des transports pour permettre
aux personnes âgées notamment à leur
domicile d'accéder à la vaccination et
j'en viens c'est mon dernier point sur
la traduction sur la territorialisation
du plan de relance qui évidemment la
traduction dans les territoires du plan
de relance mais il ya aussi la des
attentes sur le fait que les besoins des
collectivités soient mieux pris en
compte en gros que le plan de relance ne
se résume pas je le dis un peu cash mais
aux unique priorité de l'état et qui est
un dialogue entre les priorités
évidemment affichée par l'état et les
besoins des collectivités
vous avez évoqué une clause de revoyure
si j'ai bien compris qui permettrait que
des crédits non consommés puisse être
redéployés
quelles seraient les marges dans ce
contexte là j'ai un sujet en tête mais
je sais qu'il ne concerne pas uniquement
mon département qui celui de la seine
maritime c'est par exemple la défense
incendie qui est quelque chose qui lie
l'état aux collectivités et bien est-ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas imaginer que dans
le cadre du plan de relance des
financements soient déployés pour
équiper nos communes au regard des
exigences en matière de défense incendie
merci c'est une pour cette question sur
la verticalité des choses
berlin et philippe oui merci madame la
présidente remercie d'abord d'avoir
organisé cette rencontre importante sur
les questions des finances des
collectivités et merci à vous monsieur
le ministre de d'être présent
aujourd'hui je voudrais vraiment toute
sincérité m'associer à propos de laurent
beurre berlin et à mon tour vous
remercier pour votre disponibilité votre
écoute à toute épreuve les réponses
toujours précise que vous apportez votre
pragmatisme et votre approche objective
des choses c'est sincère et je sais que
c'est largement partagé alors moi je
voudrais aborder un sujet parce qu'en
fait on a deux sujets il ya un sujet qui
et c'est ce qu'ils concentrent nos nos
énergies en ce moment qui est de
répondre à la situation générée c'est
d'urgence à la situation générée par la
crise les pertes de recettes des
collectivités on l'a évoqué le plan de
relance bon tous ces sujets là qui sont
importants et c'est la priorité
mais il faudrait pas que laisser cette
nécessité de répondre à la situation
engendrée par la crise sanitaire masque
la nécessité me semble-t-il sur la durée
d'assurer la fiabilité et la pérennité
des ressources des collectivités
parce qu'au fil du temps alors ça ne
date pas de 2010 est ne sais pas non
plus arrêté en 2017
on voit bien qu'on a peu à peu des
structures et est fragilisé les
ressources des collectivités notamment
les ressources fiscales sa rentrée dans
le détail on pourrait parler de la
réforme de la tp
en 2010-2011 avec l'instauration du fnj
re figé dont on mesure aujourd'hui on en
a on l'a évoqué à l'occasion du pls 2021
les limites
il y a eu la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation ou les solutions qui ont
été apportées pour les collectivités
sont les meilleurs qui pouvait l'être
sans doute je pense en tous les cas mais
mais il n'empêche que dans le temps elle
pose problème et à travers le plf 2021
sur l'antique 58 vous avez en art on a
souvent évoqué essayer de répondre à la
question de l'impact de cette réforme
fiscale sur le potentiel fiscal des
collectivités donc sur la péréquation
mais on sait que la réponse qui a été
apportée on n'est pas complètement sûr
on a évoqué ce sujet avec philippe
dallier à plusieurs reprises qu'elle
sera complètement sécurisé dans le temps
il ya la baisse des impôts de production
il ya le pic dont on a pu mesurer
qu'avec la condition des périmètres des
intercommunalités il méritait sans doute
non pas d'être abandonnés par c'est un
bon système de péréquation entre le cas
je le pense mais peut-être d'être d'être
révisé bref on voit bien qu'il ya un
travail de fond à faire au delà de la
situation de crise il ya un travail de
fond à faire sur pour essayer d'assurer
aux collectivités des ressources fiables
pérennes je ne suis pas un partisan
acharné de l'autonomie fiscale parce
qu'elle peut être source aussi
d'inégalités l'autonomie fiscale
elle est intéressante si elle
s'accompagne d'un système de péréquation
important et ce qui me paraît surtout
utile c'est qu'il ait une répartition
juste et équitable des ressources des
collectivités
du coup ma question est simple c'est
au-delà des sujets d'urgence sur
lesquelles on est concentré ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il ya un travail de
fond à mener mais qu'il faudrait
peut-être engager pour l'instant sans
attendre aussi sur une réexamen et une
révision pour la mise en place de
ressources
à la fois fiscale mais globalement d'un
panier de ressources qui soient fiables
et pérennes pour pour pour les
collectivités voilà je pense qu'ils ont
simplement ajouter un point c'est que
sur la question du budget spécifique
collective aux collectivités je partage
complètement la vie de françoise gatel
et de vote monsieur le ministre à savoir
même si ça pouvait paraître intéressant
a priori je faisais partie des gens qui
soutiennent pourquoi pas quand on
travaille un peu sur ce sujet on
s'aperçoit que ça présente sans doute
plus d'inconvénients que d'avantagés et
par contre que l'idée d'un débat annuel
réservé aux finances locales pourraient
être me semble utile et intéressant et
encore une fois merci aussi pour le
groupe de travail que vous aimez en
place qui en fait un groupe de
concertation et je pense que et pourrait
avoir vocation à durer au delà de la
période de crise dont on sortira
j'espère le plus tôt possible
merci beaucoup merci je lui sors un mot
sur la d6 la rénovation énergétique
j'étais très heureux de vous entendre
dire que vous donniez les consignes aux
préfets pour changer un peu la rive du
jeu parce que dans mon département la
date limite c'était la semaine prochaine
alors pour être pour déposer les
dossiers pour un dispositif dont on a
connu à peu près les contours à la fin
les dernières et même dans un
département où il n'y a que 40 communes
est en majorité des communes plutôt
importante pour toutes les communes
moyennes
c'est très compliqué il c'est toujours
pareil il ya un espèce d'effet d'aubaine
ceux qui ont des dossiers dans le tiroir
prêts vont pouvoir les déposer et les
autres regarder passer les trains
donc j'espère effectivement quel con
s'il va arriver très vite
mais après reste évidemment le choix du
choix du roi mais choisit préfet ils
vont sélectionner tel ou tel dossier
c'est toujours la même la même
problématique certains vont passer à
côté sans trop savoir pourquoi
donc au delà du problème de procédure et
de contenu des dossiers que vous
demandez c'est vrai que moi je
m'interroge toujours franchement une
subvention d'investissement qu'ils
soient pas liées à un dossier appel à
projets qu'est-ce qu'on gagnerait comme
temps à la fois côté mairie côté
préfecture pour un résultat qui serait
là parce que si l'état avait
effectivement décidé d'attribuer une
subvention d'investissement dont fléché
a priori je pense que tous les maires
les aurait utilisés
second sujet c'est effectivement la mise
en place de la des conséquences de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation à
quelle date les maires disposeront-ils
les chiffres pour l'année 2020 t1 parce
qu'on a eu des simulations alors je
trouverais voûte
j'aime autant vous dire que les chiffres
que nous avait transmis à l'époque était
assez abscons
à quelle date les maires auront-ils
effectivement les chiffres valable pour
leurs budgets 2021 parce qu'il ya le
problème des bases et puis après le
problème des compensations alors pour le
coup celui je vais pas vous parler de
compensation de la taxe foncière pour
les bailleurs sociaux mais par exemple
tout simplement de celle de pour la taxe
d'habitation l'allée de référence on m'a
dit que c'est 2019 dont vous avez des
communes qui vont perdre à taux
équivalent qui vont perdre une partie du
produit des compensations que l'état
leur verse et en 2020
dans ce jeu de passe passe enfin voilà
il ya des incertitudes donc on nous dit
on devrait pas y perdre
tout devrait être compensée mais le
diable est dans les détails je pense que
nous y reviendrons et que certaines
communes vont avoir de mauvaise surprise
mais raison de plus pour donner les
chiffres le plus tôt possible pour que d
élaboration du budget au printemps on
sache sur quelles bases partir et c'est
particulièrement important dans un
contexte aussi incertain en matière
économique et budgétaire philippe il
nous restera ensuite l'intervention de
deux collègues qui sont en visio jean
yves perrot et sonia de la provôté merci
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente vous répondra
madame la sénatrice brulin l'évaluation
que nous avons fait d'une compensation
des pertes de recettes tarifaires que
nous n'avons pas retenu est la même que
celle que le sénat avait fait dans les
amendements qui ont été débattus ici
même soit un peu plus d'un milliard
d'euros c'est l'évaluation nous
partagions et c'est ce qui explique
pourquoi
des explications en tout cas en plus des
économies de constatations et
l'hétérogénéité nous n'avons pas retenu
cette disposition
par contre pour la compensation des
recettes fiscales et domaniale qui a été
intégré j'ai indiqué que cela
représenterait selon nos prévisions
autour de 510 millions d'euros
j'ai le sentiment que la disposition
telle qu'elle a été adoptée répondre à
votre attente c'est à dire que nous
avons pris comme base de comparaison les
trois années 2017 2018 et 2019 et vous
auriez préféré comprennent que 2019 si
j'ai bien compris
nous avons retenu les trois ans car nous
avons voulu d'une part au bénéfice des
collectivités éviter que certaines
d'entre elles soient pénalisés par des
ressauts sur les années précédentes qui
ne seraient pas prises en compte et au
bénéfice de l'état pour éviter qu'un
ruisseau en 2019 ou une augmentation
très forte entre les trois années soit
onéreuse onéreuses sur la compensation
pour l'état par ailleurs j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'indiqué cette règle des
trois ans et celle qui est communément
retenu pour le calcul des compensations
ou des mécanismes de compensation de
transfert de charges c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a fait une forme de
parallélisme des fins sur la
territorialisation je l'indiquais tout à
l'heure nous avons enfin un tipi le dire
ainsi qu avant c est publié à la fin de
l'année la circulaire qui autorise les
préfets de département une région à
contractualiser sur des plans de relance
avec des collectivités haute que les
régions sauf peut-être des
intercommunalités
notre préférence va plutôt vers des
intercommunalités taille assez
importante ou des regroupements ou avec
des départements le département de la
gironde et celui de la charente charente
et charente-maritime j'ai un doute c'est
le département dominique bussereau ont
d'ores et déjà annoncé et rendue
publique de telles signatures
ces accords se font sur des bases de
cofinancement des projets portés par les
collectivités
par contre dès lors qu'il s'agit de
mobiliser une partie des 100 milliards
d'euros du plan de relance
ça se fait en fonction des priorités du
gouvernement et de l'état sur la
question du plan de relance
si les collectivités ont des priorités
dans le cadre de l'exercice de leurs
compétences priorité qui leur
appartiennent c'est évidemment légitime
nous veillons à articuler les choses en
terme de mobilisation des finances
pour ce qui est des financements de
l'état ceux ci sont bien évidemment
mobilisé autour des priorités qui sont
les meutres assez large du du plan de
relance
la clause de revoyure que j'ai évoquées
a comme principal objectif non pas de
modifier des priorités du plan de
relance
espérant que ça ne soit pas utile mais
de veiller à ce que des projets qui
devaient être engagées dans les six
premiers mois dans les huit premiers
mois et qu'ils ne le feraient pas ou qui
aurait pris trop de retard soit
abandonnée en termes de financement au
profit de projets qui marchent très bien
d'action qui marche très bien puisque
nous avons comme objectif un
décaissement rapide puisque c'est c'est
la rapidité du décaissement et son
volume qui participent à la relance
c'est en cela que je parlais de clause
de revoyure et de suivi de ces projets
pour bernard delcros en le remerciant
bien bien évidemment le sujet abordé est
évidemment le sujet peut-être le plus
important qui est devant nous qui n'est
pas nécessairement lire les crises qu
vide vous avez rappelé l'évolution de la
fiscalité la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle en 2010 d'une part avec
le fnj redon on sait aujourd'hui que son
caractère figé et andré soucy pour les
collectivités dans la situation évoluer
depuis
de la même manière la suppression de la
part salaires en 99 avait donné lieu
d'abord un dégrèvement ensuite une
compensation et enfin une transformation
de cette compensation par une fraction
de la dgf qui explique d'ailleurs une
des une des explications à la différence
à situations parfois comparable de
niveau de dgf entre par habitant entre
entre les communes y voir plus clair et
avoir des mécanismes qui permettent de
garantir que l'on connaisse et que l'on
maîtrise les effets sur la péréquation
au delà des mécanismes de gel que nous
avons avec l'aide du cfl introduit dans
le plf 2021 est évidemment une priorité
et je pense que la pérennité la
lisibilité et le débat que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure entre autonomie
financière automne et fils autonomie
fiscale pourrait nous occuper pendant
très longtemps mais ferait à ses
fondateurs si on veut véritablement
reprendre le système de financement des
collectivités locales
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire parfois avec
un peu de provocation
le fait que si nos actions
collectivement d'aller vers l'autonomie
fiscale des collectivités
cela aurait notamment pour conséquence
que je ne serais pas devant vous pour
présenter des mesures de compensation de
recettes puisque qui dit autonomie
complète dit aussi capacité à faire face
à l'augmentation qu'à la baisse des
ressources en fonction de la nature de
celle qui est affectée mais mais ce
débat là qui me passionne par ailleurs
peut-être est prématuré dans une
situation de crise comme celle que nous
vivons mais en tout cas je partage
l'intérêt de le mener je profite de
votre intervention pour vous dire que
conformément à ce que nous avions évoqué
ensemble lors du débat l'ordonance qui
permet aux régies thermale public de
bénéficier de la prise en charge de
l'activité partielle vous aviez évoqué
le sujet pour des des stations notamment
dans dans le massif central a été publié
le 21 décembre avec un caractère
rétroactif et donc pour les régies
publiques des régies thermale public
c'est la prise en compte de l'activité
partielle qui qui paie qui manquait qui
pêchaient est désormais possible
enfin pour la question de la dessine
rénovation énergétique je prends le
point sur les délais il faut qu'ils
manquaient un peu de souplesse et il
faire extrêmement attention qu elles
sont des critères de choix que nous
avons indiqué au préfet pour
l'attribution de ces financements sont
les deux mêmes critères que ceux qui ont
été retenus par l'état pour la sélection
de ses propres projets à hauteur de
milliards 7
la preuve la performance énergétique
d'une part et je précise que nous sommes
sûrs de la rénovation n'est pas de la
construction pour être tout à fait
précis sur le champ de ce qui sera
accompagnée et le deuxième critère qui
est très impératif et même tout à fait
impératif pour les istréens des comptes
publics et la relance est celui de la
relance c'est la capacité et
l'engagement des porteurs de projets est
ce que les marchés publics soient
notifiées au cours de l'année 2000 21
puisque si nous voulons pousser la
relance il faut que ces marchés publics
sont notifiés compris pour les
collectivités les entreprises puissent
s'en servir auprès de leur banque en
termes de trésorerie et donc c'est là le
le critère pour nos principales c'est
ses marchés publics ans en 2020 21
pardon pour vous donner une illustration
je ne sais pas ce sera la même chose que
des collectivités l'état avait deux
milliards sept pour ses bâtiments et
ceux des universités
nous avons reçu en un mois puisque
l'appel à projets avait été ouverte le 7
octobre a clôturé le 7 septembre et
clôturer le 9 octobre
nous avons reçu pour 8 milliards 4,2
projet dont nous avons gardé deux
milliards sept et je ne sais pas si on
sera dans les mêmes ordres de grandeur
pour les collectivités on sait qu'il ya
des besoins et de la demande
donc vraiment que ça puisse pousser des
entreprises du territoire enfin nous
aurons des premières indications sur la
question des bases et des compensations
normalement la semaine prochaine les
bases définitive de th seront
communiqués comme à l'accoutumée en mars
nous n'avons pas de retard qui nous
mentent aux aucun retard signalé
aujourd'hui sur les états fiscaux et les
notifications la volonté de prendre en
compte les compensations et bien au
rendez vous je ne sais pas vous répondre
sur l'année 2019 ou pas par rapport au
vote des abattements
mais je vois là je vais le vérifier on
reviendra vers vous parce que je ne sais
pas il répondra à cet instant par contre
nous avons fait en sorte est d'ores et
déjà prévu que les rôles supplémentaire
pour 2020 pourraient être ajoutés aux
bases de compensation justement pour
tenir compte du caractère atypique de
l'année et éviter que telle ou telle
scories se traduisent par une
dépréciation des compensations pour les
collectivités et beaucoup donc la parole
est un autre collègue jean yves cros
suivi de sonia de la provôté qui tous
les deux sont en visio jean-yves le
ministre
écoutez moi je suis aussi très heureux
2-2 d'être présent avec nouveau
auditionné monsieur le ministre vous
avez toujours des réponses qui sont très
claires et très précis et cela nous
accompagne pour si on monte les
informations et données d'information de
l'état sur nos territoires
moi ma question concerne la réforme de
la tgap en milieu rural plus
particulièrement vous savez l'articuler
du projet de loi de finances pour 2010 9
loyer in omne prévoit une augmentation
de 1,6 pour ça en 2019 de la tgap en
2021 chaque tonne de déchets non
dangereux a envoyé un stockage est
majoré de 12 euros tandis que la
majoration sera le 5 euros ou une tonne
de déchets qui est non dangereux qui
sera envoyée à l'incinération
donc je salue bien sûr l'objectif
principal est de la tgap qui le faire
changer les pratiques
les comportements en matière de déchets
mais dans ce contexte les
intercommunalités qui assume la
compétence liés à la collecte et au
traitement des ordures ménagères font
face à des augmentations de charges sans
précédent avaient leurs engagements et
puis l engagement pour essayer de faire
baisser le volume de déchets dont ils
ont la responsabilité
vous savez je suis je suis sénateur des
alpes provence et de nombreuses
initiatives ont été prises en faveur des
consignes de tri l'optimisation des
collectes aussi un milieu rural avec des
parents des points d'apport volontaire
or qu'on le conte tout le monde le dit
la situation économique est très
défavorable pour les collectivités qui
vendent je veux dire les matériaux
véritable affaire tu avais des prix de
reprise de ces matériaux qui ont
fortement baissé en 2020 ce qui obère
les finances des collectivités
territoriales dans son contexte
l'augmentation qui prévu de 50% de la
tgap due à la réforme à partir de jamais
2020 et écrit une charge très importante
et très difficilement soutenable pour
les administrés mais aussi pour les
collectivités dans ma question est
simple monsieur le ministre
est ce qu'il est possible d'envisager un
mécanisme de lissage de l'augmentation
de cette réforme qui prévu et c'est
aussi le jeter en 2023 je vous remercie
et merci beaucoup chers collègues la
parole et à sonia de la provôté chers
collègues
merci monsieur ministre de la précision
de vos réponses et du temps pris moi ma
question m à la fois général est à la
fois tout à fait d'actualité dans la
contribution des dents dans l'âme le
fonctionnement local des collectivités
la contribution de l'état est éminemment
importante
il a été décidé que les collectivités
locales aient moins d'impact sur la
fiscalité il n'y a pas d'impact sur les
taxes les contributions des autres
collectivités entre elles ou travers de
projets ne vont pas augmenter dans les
années à venir parce que chacun de
rencontrer ses propres difficultés
arbitrage le en matière budgétaire
en ce qui concerne le mécénat ou les
contributions tv on s'attend pas non
tu avoir une augmentation des
contributions ont les années à venir dès
lors sur comme on à moi la main sur la
fiscalité que finalement l'autonomie
fiscale va abaisser la question va être
quand même celle de l'autonomie
financière et donc de la partie
décisionnelle des collectivités locales
sur les arbitrages des contributions des
taxes ce soit au travers évidemment des
dotations des subventions des
contractualisations on viens d'entendre
sur le plan de la france par exemple est
ce que une partie des subventions pour
être non fléchés et ne pas dépendre des
décisions et des priorités de l'état et
que les collectivités et la main sur cet
arbitrage de répartition budgétaire
puisque finalement ces budgets ces
crédits ils viennent des territoires ils
sont pas que de l'état ou que des
collectivités ils sont avant tout des
contribuables et via des territoires
donc il serait légitime dans ce grand
débat que nous avons sur les arbitrages
budgétaires et finalement l'évolution
que l'on souhaite voir unir sur le
fonctionnement financier budgétaires des
collectivités locales qui est une
réflexion sur la part que l'état dans ce
grand package qu'on a qualifié de
dotations de l'état
une réflexion sur la part que l'état est
prêt à laisser aux collectivités locales
pour qu'elles aient la main dessus et
qu'elle retrouve une part d'autonomie et
de liberté dans la façon dont cet argent
finalement qui vient des territoires et
qui retourne au territoire puisse
accompagner la différenciation
d'autonomie locale
les projets locaux notamment je pense au
projet porté par les maires ou par les
intercommunalités
parce que à trop mettre deux cadres et à
ne pas laisser la main sur une part de
liberté et bien finalement le danger est
grand de voir cette fameuse
différenciation devenir une
différenciation de papier et une défense
à sion du publicité est pas une
différenciation dans les faits la
différenciation et n'existera que si les
collectivités ont les moyens financiers
de la mettre en oeuvre
okou cher collègue monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente pour répondre
aux sénateurs roues c'est un sujet qui a
été évoqué aucune disposition n'a été
adopté dans la loi de finances pour
permettre le lissage de l'augmentation
de la tgap telles qu'elles avaient été
prévues
il est maintenant quelques années ou
quelques mois avec la loti danse rappelé
par les sénateurs
si nous étions et je n'en ai pas
l'utilité au delà des exemples que je
que je le crois volontiers mais
l'utilité global ce lissage il faudrait
une disposition législative donc rien n
est possible avant un éventuel plfr et
je ne cache pas qu'au delà de l'intérêt
du sujet je ne suis pas spécialement
pressé que nous ayons besoin d'un plfr
en ce début d'année mais c'est un point
que nous allons regarder sur lesquels
nous allons pouvoir avancer sur les
remarques plus que les questions de
madame la sénatrice de la prévôté là
j'ai un point de désaccord de principe
dans la mesure où je considère qu'il n'y
a pas un contribuable local et un
contribuable national et que si on
considère que les impôts nationaux
collectées par l'état c'est même
émission mais si on considère que les
impôts nationaux collectées par l'état
parce qu'il s'agit d'impôts nationaux
devraient être restituées aux
territoires pour que les élus locaux en
face strictement ce qu'ils veulent et
sans cadre
cela signifierait que l'état assumerait
l'augmentation ou la période de collecte
des impôts mais pas son usage
si vous comprenez que c'est un peu
compliqué à envisager il y à des
montants de concours financiers qui sont
libres d usage
je pense notamment à la dgf nous avons
aussi veiller avec les dotations
d'investissement qui sont maintenus je
le rappelle est augmentée dans le cadre
du plan de relance
même s'il ya des critères à laisser le
maximum de marge de manoeuvre que les
collectivités souhaitent s'inscrire dans
un plan de relance et avoir des actions
différencier je le répète c'est légitime
et à chaque fois que nous pouvons
l'article est mon article ont par contre
effet rejoint la réponse que je faisais
là madame la sénatrice brulin tout à
l'heure pour ce qui concerne les
financements qu'ils sont
acte est proposé et voté par le
parlement mais acté par proposer direct
et par le gouvernement et par l'état il
s'agit des priorités qui sont celles de
l'état qui seront financés et mises en
oeuvre
nous avons malgré tout je pense
notamment aux enveloppes de ds il on
sait qu'il ya quelques critères sur la
ds il je suis précise que cela des si
l'extraordinaire glee à la crise nous
avons veillé à ce que les critères
soient la fois ceux de la destinée de la
detr pour n'écarter aucun territoire
nous avons malgré tout des concours
assez importants qui sont sinon libre
usage en tout cas assez faciles à
déployer sur des projets uniquement
portées par les collectivités
si merci monsieur le ministre je crois
que nous avons permis à tous nos
collègues qui le souhaitaient de poser
des qui sera juste en écho peut-être
quelques remarques ou quelques
observations on voit met en travers des
questions qui sont posées comment on
peut assumer ce qu'on appelle la libre
administration des collectivités
j'ai un petit point de désaccord avec
vous monsieur mise quand vous dites que
la dgf peut-être utiliser librement et
sans doute mais toutefois néanmoins il
cependant
je rappelle que la dotation globale de
fonctionnement est versée par l'état
pour que les collectivités assume au nom
de l'étape des compétences donc va après
je pense que derrière toutes ces
questions financières il ya aussi la
conception 2d l'articulation entre les
acteurs de l'action publique l'état
régalien à ses fonctions n'a besoin d'un
état fort et puissant nul ne peut le
nier on a besoin de péréquation mon
collègue bernard des crocs et d'autres
les voient occasions et en même temps si
je puis dire
il faut que les collectivités locales
puissent financer des investissements
des dépenses qui leur sont prioritaires
contenu
de la nature de leur population de la
nature de leur territoire donc comment
on trouve cette commande trouve cet
équilibre et puis au travers des
questions on y retourne bien autour de
de la décentralisation ou de la
déconcentration c'est à dire on a soit
un partenaire qui est l'état qui
pratiquent la verticalité celle qui dit
à juste titre à raison monsieur le mini
van hamme et priorités et l'état a le
droit d'afficher les priorités donc vous
venez vous inscrire dans ses priorités
et moi je vous aide
si vos projets sont dans ma logique et
en même temps si je puis dire
on doit cultiver l'idée d'une république
ascendante
parce qu'on doit pouvoir prendre en
compte des besoins légitimes et des
aspirations des le responsable mais qui
partent des réalités territoire alors
cesser un conflit sans doute difficile à
gérer mais je crois qu'il faut pas qu'on
oublie donc j'ai noté qu'un terme
sioniste que vous disiez que quand on
commençait à l'heure on était parfois un
peu en retard je pense que l'on va finir
un peu avant donc vous voyez comment le
sénat est très attentive à vos souhaits
je veux vraiment monsieur le ministre
vous remercier en mon nom personnel et
en d'autres noms à tous parce que chacun
a dit ici je crois que le les sénateurs
apprécié votre assiduité au sénat votre
confrontation avec des questions des
visions qui sont parfois un peu
différent de vos réponses toujours très
claires et donc ce respect que vous avez
de la conception notre démocratie qui
fonctionne sur deux piliers l'état le
parlement
et puis naturellement il y a le 3e
piliers que sont les collectivités alors
vraiment moi je veux vous remercier vous
dire combien on apprécie tout ça
maintenant monsieur le ministre mais je
sais que vous êtes très clairvoyant ne
confondez pas la grande satisfaction que
l'on a travaillé avec vous avec une
satisfaction sur le fond de ce que vous
nous proposez je me sentais quand même
obligés de
le dire sinon vous n'auriez pas reconnu
voilà donc vraiment monsieur ministre
merci merci beaucoup moi je note et ça
n'était pas un piège aux questions que
je vous ai posé sur les propositions du
sénat je note
on va dire votre intérêt ou votre
adhésion moi j'aimerais que vous nous
aidiez avant c'est aussi dans ce sens là
parce que je crois que c'est un sens
très positif pour les tailles nos
collectivités enfin je me permette de
vous souhaiter à vous et à votre équipe
une très bonne année monsieur très bon
allez monsieur mini ce match à vous
merci madame la présidente je vous aurez
reconnu mais pas nécessairement cru
semble voir les choses différemment
je saisis l'occasion pardonnez moi de le
faire après votre intervention de
clôture pour dire qu'il abrite
tout à l'heure j'ai indiqué que
l'augmentation des allocations
individuelles de solidarité
en réponse à monsieur le sénateur burgoa
madame la sénatrice pris l'un était de 6
ans je précise que c'est toute
allocation de solidarité confondues
danger si on se centre sur le salaire et
ça on est à 7 % ce qui est différent
mais ma conseillère qui m'accompagne me
glisser cette précision juste titre
c'est 1,6 pour cent pour tout les ars 7%
si on se concentre sur lui reste pour
que le débat soit parfaitement clair sur
ce sujet là tout cas merci à toutes et à
tous et à très bientôt qu'un petit post
custom excusez moi monsieur mini
j'oublie mais qui est important j'ai cru
entendre lorsque nous avons parlé du
groupe de travail sur le financement des
collectivités j'ai cru vous entendre
dire que vous associé au groupe de
travail technique
les collaborateurs des parlementaires
concernés donc moi j'ai juste voilà on a
échangé avec marc le dha et je ne pense
pas qu'à ce jour les colas les
administrateurs de la délégation et
était sollicité donc si je n'ai pas mal
compris ce que vous avez dit voilà nous
serons très heureux de participer aux
travaux préparatoires
merci monsieur me
[Musique]